hello everyone in this video I am going
to address a few points to the students
who are feeling unhappy with their seat
allocation after the jossa counseling is
over this happiness may be stemming
because of the department that they have
been allocated or perhaps The Institute
or perhaps both
now before I can address these points I
would like to mention one thing so it is
very natural for us as human beings to
feel very lonely when we are unhappy
perhaps you are feeling that you are the
only one going through this grief and
distress of not getting your favorite
department or Institute but just think
about it logically for a minute
when the students of your batch or the
general body of students they start
preparing for JE
almost everyone has this dream of going
to computer science at IIT Bombay
maybe you have not been so ambitious but
at least perhaps you wanted to go to
some circular branch in one of the older
iits everyone has this dream
but
after the Joshua counseling is over you
can imagine that only a few hundred
students get to realize the stream so it
means that after the josia counseling is
over despite the fact that you all have
been successful in J means NJ advanced
you all end up being unhappy so this is
the situation with the vast majority of
the students okay so you are not alone
in your grief not by any measure okay
so with that out of the way let us get
to the point uh what to do and what not
to do if you are unhappy with your
department the first and most important
thing to note is that stop trying to
escape from your department even before
you have joined it
okay I have seen this happen in many
many cases this is an absolutely uh
unwise thing to do
this escapism can be in the form of
trying to go for a department change
even before you have joined the
Department or perhaps trying to think of
some kind of an uh of a future IIT job
that you have to take up because somehow
you want to escape from your department
okay this is absolutely unwise and a
strategically bad thing to do for your
entire career because even before
joining the department if you start
thinking like that whatever good
whatever little good that may have
happened to you in the department that
that has been allocated to you that also
will not happen Okay so stop trying to
escape from it now I understand that
this kind of an escapism feeling it
appears most of the time because of the
students facing some kind of
preconceived bias against the department
because of uh whatever they may have
heard from this and that place so
my advice would be that first try to
find out a little bit what is uh going
on in the department that you have been
allocated meaning that
uh the Professional Engineers of this
department are civil engineering for
example aerospace engineering mechanical
engineering what are they doing in their
professional career and I guarantee you
that you will be a little bit surprised
by the kind of exciting things that they
actually do
so instead of getting biased by some
kind of preconceived notions try to form
your opinions like a proper adult based
on proper information so try to find out
the extremely exciting things the nice
things that Professional Engineers
coming out of your department actually
do
next even if you are not convinced by
that I would say that try to see and
hear yeah the internet is your best
friend try to find out the Cutting Edge
things that are going on in your
department
okay in terms of research
many a Time students at the beginning of
their career they have absolutely no
idea about the absolutely fascinating
things the awesome things that are going
on in the department because uh
they have these kinds of very limited
knowledge by what they have what they
have heard from their parents and
relatives and friends and the
unfortunate thing is that with all due
respect to these people they are also
ignorant okay in terms of these high
level things so you are not like that
okay you are you have to be better than
that so try to form an informed opinion
okay and I'll come to this a little bit
later about this point of whom to listen
to and whom not to listen to next
suppose you are somewhat okay with your
allocated department but you are not so
happy with your allocated Institute
so maybe you had this dream Institute
which you know never got to
uh which you never got allocated so my
advice would be at this point uh please
do not uh feel sorry for yourself okay
so
the best thing at this point would be to
actually find out a little bit about the
history of the Institute that you are
going to
okay now
you are all technically oriented
students but still this kind of a little
bit of learning the history of the
Institute can be a source of immense
inspiration to you
and mind you
every Institute has some part of a
glorious history about it there have
been some fabulous alumni that have come
out from many of the institutes even if
those institutes are not your so-called
dream Institutes
some fascinating
professionals have come out from their
both in the core field as well as in the
non-core field
many bits of fascinating research work
is also going on in these various
institutes that you have no idea about
okay so this is this is an extremely
good time to find out the absolutely
fabulous things that may be going on in
The Institute my actual advice here
would be is that is there is something
actionable and concrete that you can do
is why don't you just go and set up a
Google alert for your Institute okay
suppose you have been suppose you are
going to so and so IIT okay or so and so
nit
set up a Google alert that it's it takes
like just a minute to set it up so from
the next day onwards Whenever there is
some kind of a interesting news
associated with that Institute maybe it
is in terms of some kind of professional
achievement of some faculty member or
some student or some kind of fascinating
research work that may have been done
within the Institute you will get to
know and by taking this very small step
very easy step you can actually start
gaining a lot of appreciation and actual
gratefulness that you have been
allocated a seat in so and so Institute
okay this is my promise to use just find
it out you will see the difference in
your opinion that will occur
finally I would like to say one thing
which I have already mentioned a little
bit earlier is that please please stop
listening to your
uh to to some relatives who may be
giving you some kind of unwanted advice
or maybe uh some kind of neighborhood
aunties and aunts who may be your well
wishes I'm not saying that they are they
are not wishing good for you they may be
your well wishes but with all due
respect to them at the end of the day
they are
for most Parts quite ignorant of what is
going on in the different departments
and Institutes
so if they are ignorant okay you think
about it just logically
when it comes to a mechanics problem
okay simple mechanics problem
the kind of things that you do in your
plus two
for the simplest of problems you would
not trust them to draw even the free
body diagram for you these uncles and
aunties so why will you let these uncles
and aunties with their ignorance dictate
your thought processes and your decision
making why would you let them comment
about it so do not let them disturb your
mind be absolutely free be very
steadfast in what you have decided what
you have been allocated and go forth and
try to find out the best about it this
will give you a very positive energy
when you are trying to go now when when
you will be going to your actual when
you'll be actually joining your
Institute and your department and this
positive energy will actually Propel you
to extract the best possible thing out
of your carrier okay so this is my
heartfelt wish and advice to you all the
very very best thank you